تتعرض روسيا لهجمات على
أراضيها وكذلك على مدينة ساحلية رئيسية
في أوكرانيا المحتلة، وينضم إلينا
مراسلنا الدولي الكبير سام كيلي
على الهواء مباشرة من شرق أوكرانيا.
يحاول المسؤولون الروس طمأنة
السكان الذين يعيشون تحت سيطرة الكرملين،
لكن هذه الهجمات حقيقية.
بالإضافة إلى المدمنين المكثفين الذين
أشرت إليهم هناك،
كان هناك هجوم خاص بهم
في سمالينسك على مصفاة لتكرير النفط أو
أي مبنى مماثل وبالطبع
كانوا مستمرين في التوغلات
والهجمات الأقرب إلى هنا شمالًا
على الحدود بين أوكرانيا وروسيا،
وأعتقد أن تلك هي التي
هزت الروس حقًا بسبب
الضربة الأوكرانية في
الطيور التي يحتلها الروس، ماوم، تزداد
سخونة عبر عدة جبهات في
روسيا، ويكافح حاكم مقاطعة بلغارد
لطمأنة السكان المضطربين.
سمعت ذلك  تواصل القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية
قصف أراضينا،
ويقيم أكثر من 2500 شخص في
مرافق الإقامة المؤقتة في
بلغراد، وهناك العديد من الأسئلة التي
يطرحها سكان تشيفي كينو والقرى الحدودية بدءًا من من
سيدفع المرافق الخاصة بي وماذا عن
ممتلكاتنا ومن يراقبها  يزعم
جنود منشقون روس مدعومون من أوكرانيا أنهم قاموا بمداهمة روسيا
للمرة الثانية
في حركة يمكن تصويرها في
أي مكان يعرض فيه أحد المقاتلين
مغناطيس ثلاجة من بلغراد على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي،
وقريبًا ستتمكن أيضًا من المشي في
بلغراد الحرة ثم في جميع أنحاء البلاد.  روسيا قال إن
فلاديمير بوتين تدخل
لتهدئة الأعصاب الوطنية
اليوم، وسنتناول أيضًا هذه القضايا
فيما يتعلق بضمان
أمن روسيا في هذه الحالة، الأمن السياسي الداخلي، مع الأخذ في
الاعتبار الجهود التي
لا يزال أعداؤنا يبذلونها ويكثفونها من أجل زعزعة
استقرار الوضع في الداخل.
يجب على روسيا أن تفعل كل ما في وسعها لمنع
حدوث ذلك بأي ثمن،
وتوضح الولايات المتحدة بعض الحقائق القاتمة
لموسكو عندما تنظر إلى
الأهداف والغايات الاستراتيجية طويلة المدى للرئيس بوتين،
فلا شك أن وضع
روسيا اليوم أسوأ بكثير
مما كان عليه من قبل.  قبل
غزوها واسع النطاق لأوكرانيا عسكريًا
واقتصاديًا
وجيوسياسيًا،
هذه بالتأكيد هي الرسالة التي
تحاول أوكرانيا إيصالها إلى روسيا
والآن بالقوة، وقد تم
تسليم هذه الرسالة بقوة مرة أخرى من خلال
هجوم حزبي أعلنه
أنصار أوكرانيا داخل بلدة
ماليتا المحتلة.  القطب مع تفجير سيارة
مما أسفر عن مقتل أحد المتعاونين المزعومين
وإصابة ثلاثة آخرين على الأقل،
ونحن نشهد الكثير من هذا النوع من
الأحداث، لا سيما بالقرب من تلك
الجبهة الجنوبية حيث يقصف الجانبان كلا من
الروس والأوكرانيين
كل منهما.  أخرى أكثر
ندرة مع المدفعية أليكس
نعم حقًا تصعيد ملحوظ سام
كيلي في هاركي بشرق أوكرانيا،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك على هذا التقرير،
دعنا نناقش كل هذا مع جيل دوجيرتي،
المساهمة في الشؤون الروسية في CNN،
والعقيد المتقاعد سيدريك
لايتون، محلل عسكري في CNN، أه شكرًا
كلاكما لانضمامكما إلي هذا المساء،
جيل، لقد أذهلتني تلك
المقطوعة الصوتية التي عزفها سام للتو من فلاديمير
بوتين، حيث يؤكدون لشعبه
أننا سنبذل كل ما في وسعنا
لمنع حدوث ذلك بأي ثمن
يتكبده حقًا.  لإخبار
السكان الروس أه أن هذا سيكون على ما يرام
ماذا تعتقد أنه سيفعل كيف
يمكنه الوفاء بهذا الوعد
لا أعتقد أنه يستطيع أعني أن هذه
الهجمات قادمة يبدو أنهم غير قادرين
على إيقافها أعني إذا كانوا  هل يمكن أن يفعلوا ذلك
لكنهم يستمرون، ثم
لديك هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار
قبل بضعة أيام فقط في موسكو، لذلك أعتقد أن لديه
مشكلة حقيقية في
الكثير من الطريقة التي يقترب بها وهي
عدم التحدث عنها، كما تعلم ولكن
حقيقة ذلك  لديهم هذا الاقتباس اليوم وهو
يحاول إخبار الناس أن الأمر على ما يرام لأنه
يقول دائمًا إن الأمر تحت السيطرة ولكنه
ليس تحت السيطرة ويشعر هؤلاء
السكان بالتأكيد أنه
ليس تحت السيطرة وسيدريك بعض
اللغة الدرامية التي
يقولها الأوكراني أن أبواب  لقد بدأت الحرب الآن
بشكل واضح، فهذه الهجمات داخل
روسيا أه تؤدي إلى اختلال
توازن الكرملين، ويبدو أنهم مضطربون
أيضًا ولكن هل ترى أي جانب سلبي أو أي
مخاطر على هذا البئر، هناك بالتأكيد أليكس
وأعتقد أن أحد الأشياء الرئيسية التي
يجب على الأوكرانيين أن ينتبهوا إلى
مهاجمة عدد كبير جدًا من الأهداف المدنية في
روسيا. وأنا أعلم الآن أنهم على
أرض أخلاقية عالية، وهم يملكون كل
ذلك لأن الأشخاص الذين
يهاجمون بالفعل أهدافًا مدنية هم
الروس في معظمهم و  لقد
منح ذلك أوكرانيا الكثير من الدعم بالمعنى
المادي بالمعنى الدبلوماسي
وبالتأكيد بالمعنى العسكري وأنت تعلم أن
أوكرانيا تخاطر بشيء
كبير جدًا هنا إذا فعلت شيئًا
لا يؤثر على الهدف العسكري
بشكل مباشر بمعنى آخر إذا  إنهم يذهبون إلى
الجانب المدني من الأمور لذا عليهم
أن يكونوا حذرين للغاية وأن يركزوا
أكثر على الجانب العسكري ونعم حتى
على الجانب السياسي ولكن الشيء الوحيد
الذي فعلوه بشكل جيد للغاية هو
عدم الثقة في الإرهاب في أذهان
الروس  لقد قال البيت الأبيض بوضوح
شديد إنهم يفضلون
عدم رؤية أوكرانيا تضرب داخل
روسيا وجيل. أصبح من الواضح جدًا الآن
للمواطنين الروس
أنفسهم أن هذه الضربات
تحدث، لديك هذه الهجمات ضد
بلدات حدودية أصغر في الغرب  جزء
من روسيا ولكن لديك أيضًا هذه
الهجمات الأخيرة بطائرات بدون طيار بالقرب من موسكو بما في ذلك داخل
وحول حي
يعيش فيه بعض النخبة، إلى أي مدى
تعتقد أن المشاعر الروسية تجاه
الحرب تتغير وتتغير
أكثر ضدها، كما تعلم  أعتقد أنه من
المثير للاهتمام
أننا شاهدنا للتو مقطع الفيديو من
شيبيكينو، أعني أنه تم ضربه لعدة
أشهر ولم يتحدث أحد عنه حقًا،
يشعر الناس هناك أنك تعلم
أنك لا تتحدث عنه حتى يحدث
في موسكو، لذلك أعتقد أن ما تريده  "نرى
الاختلافات الطبقية بين النخبة
مقابل الأشخاص العاديين الذين
تأثروا بالحرب وأه، كما تعلمون
قدرًا معينًا من نوع المقاومة حتى أن
العمدة يبدو غير مرتاح جدًا
بشأن ما يحدث بشكل ملحوظ لقد
تحدث بوتين بالفعل عبر الهاتف و
اتصلت به بالأمس وقلت ماذا
تحتاج
مرة أخرى كما تعلم محاولًا طمأنة الناس
أم العقيد لم يبق لدينا سوى لحظات قليلة
ولكننا جميعًا ننتظر هذا
الهجوم المضاد بالطبع ليبدأ بشكل
جدي أه بمجرد أن يبدأ بكل
جديد  لقد حصلوا على كل
الأسلحة الجديدة التي حصلوا عليها،
ما هي التحديات التي
سيواجهونها فيما يتعلق
باختراق الخط الروسي
واستعادة الأراضي الروسية المحتلة، لذا
خلال هذه الفترة التي كنا
ننتظرها منك  لديك كل هذه
الفخاخ للدبابات التي تم بناؤها، لديك كل
المواضع المختلفة، جميع
الخنادق، كل نوع من الأشياء التي
يمكن للروس أن يرميوها على هذا، لقد
ألقوها على هذا، لذلك لديهم
خط دفاعي قوي جدًا الآن هذا الخط هو
فقط  أقوياء طالما أن الأشخاص في
الجيش الروسي يقفون على هذا الخط إذا
لم يكونوا هناك إذا
انشقوا إذا كانوا يعرفون يتراجعون إذا فعلوا أي شيء من
هذا القبيل أو أو الحلوى اه،
فستكون فوضى كبيرة
ويمكن للأوكرانيين أن يفعلوا ذلك  استغل ذلك
كثيرًا، حسنًا، ما زلنا ننتظر أن
يبدأ هذا، العقيد سيدريك كلايتون،
جيل دوهرتي، شكرًا جزيلاً لك دائمًا،
نقدر أفكارك
الأجنبية